well there's this one girl I don't know
I get into the detail no you know the
interesting thing is if since I started
this about the age of 12 to 14 and got
to know more and more about how people
are fooled and how they fool themselves
the two things that magicians must know
I I don't think I've ever been fooled by
an illusion Oh sometimes but I first see
it on stage y'all say whoa how about
that oh yeah I think about it and I say
okay yes right there you go I will come
up with the with the solution eventually
and as a matter of fact when sitting
sitting at a car for you Joe for example
and he always puts me in the fourth row
or so and I always could move a little
bit further factly if I don't want to be
looking straight up his nose you see and
what happens is I'll sit with a magician
friend and will nudge one another at a
certain point say oh wow how about that
and people around me to say how about
what they didn't see anything happened
you see but we saw the moment of truth
you know when when he might have done
something just like this or or like it
looks innocuous but that's when the
thing happened Jesse and we recognized
that that moment of truth is something
that we spot and the people around don't
and then when the girl jumps out of the
box they're all surprised and we knew it
all along
well magic performances in many cases
and particularly some of the young folks
that are coming along these days are and
particularly in Asia oh my goodness
Asia has pretty well taken over the
magic business as far as as numbers of
people very very confident people who
are in the business male and female they
really do a wonderful job but I am an
old-fashioned fuddy-duddy you see I can
them I stand outside my home in Fort
Lauderdale Florida and I could watch a
sunset had my eyes will fill up with
tears they tan because that's nature and
I see a whisky a raccoon crossed the
lawn and stop and look at me and I say
hello and he doesn't know what I'm
saying but he goes on his way and he
does his thing that's wonderful these
are little things that I still take
great joy and I I like seeing the world
and how it works that's why one reason
why these people who try to sell us a
false bill of goods about how the world
really works and how really wonderful it
is oh my I can't stand that I just I
find myself repelled by that idea and I
want to drag kids out into the in the
sunset and say take a look at that or a
sunrise even better at my age you
appreciate sunrises more than sunsets
you see but I've had you know I have a
very good quality telescope for example
at my home in Plantation Florida and
I'll get out the tripod to show some
guests always Jupiter's up there or
whatever or the moon or Andromeda if it
happens to be and and a good aspect I'll
show them that and kids come by on
bicycles and stop and say what you doing
and I say oh come and they look in there
and they what's that that's the planet
Jupiter and you know how far away it is
and then I'll turn to the moon and I'll
say and you know that's a quarter miles
out in space and this is and they'll say
oh yeah really and then I'll show their
Andromeda and say now that's not the way
it looks now
no no that's the way it looked
quite a few million years ago the light
is just reaching us now and when you see
them go oh you know where you've made a
hit that's important and if that kid
comes by with the girlfriend the next
day on another bike
can we see your telescope I've won a
battle right there that's important
you've got to get to kids you've got to
get to them and say take a look at this
this may surprise you and if you can do
that and be successful at it oh that
makes my day if not a week
you